mic Francesa from WFAN in new york city
joining me here on the program how are
you Mike
I'm fine rich thank you thanks for the
nice words and yeah it was one of those
days that you like being on the air I
mean those those are what you'll miss
around this that forum is special and
when you have those days where
everyone's listening and you know the
cities were something it was one of
those days yesterday they don't come
along that often but when they are there
they're very interesting and they're a
lot of fun they really are and yesterday
was wonderful might remember the show it
was kind of very much as a surprising
turn of events it really well well I
mean walking through the process I know
and this is so unguent like Mike III I
don't understand how this happened a few
weeks ago I said on this show here there
was no way the Giants the marrows and
the Tisha's would ever let Ben McAdoo
decide how to script Eli Manning's final
days with the Giants and it seems like
that's what they're doing Mike well this
is so unguent like on so many levels
first of all the credo of Wellington
Mara was always that he would reserve
judgment on a season until it was over
and his idea of a good season was a
season where you played the last game
for something now that was not going to
be the case this year but what was going
to be important was they have all their
division rivals all their storied
opponents coming into their building in
the final weeks of the season the
Cowboys the Eagles the Redskins on New
Year's Eve and how this team would
compete and how much pride it would show
and how much and it would be there would
really tell the decision for the owner
of what he should do going forward that
was all blown up today
I did not heard the news because the
news was relayed to me very differently
than it turned out to be the first news
was they were going to play both
quarterbacks and they were going to
especially look at Webb who they
talk about liking but they haven't had a
lot of work with them and that that was
the idea for the process for the last
weeks which was still not going to be
seen as a favorable move but very
different than what I heard minutes
later when McAdoo said that this gave
his team the best chance of winning and
then that just made everything
completely different that was absolutely
as the theater of the absurd now the
best chance you have to win is with Eli
on the bench and Geno Smith playing in a
week where you're not even playing the
youngster he's not even dressing this
week and now Geno Smith hey Eli it's
been told you'll play to protect the
streak but then Gina will play what wait
a second how can you tell me you trying
to win the game if you're already
deciding you playing multiple
quarterbacks in in a game that counts I
mean that's the most ridiculous thing
and to me trying to wonder what the
mcadoo motivation is here was I believe
that he and Reese decided we need more
mobility even though Geno is not an
overly mobile quarterback he is a pocket
quarterback and a bad one the other
thing is I think they want to send a
message that they're looking to next
year that maybe they can push the talk
to next year and the vision the next
year that maybe they see next year but
none of that is going to work with the
most shocking part of this all which has
been that according to McAdoo and I
can't verify this yet that John Maris
signed off on this which is the most
shocking piece to this whole puzzle that
they would treat Eli Manning it was one
of the storied iconic figures in the
history of their franchise a two-time
Super Bowl MVP and one of the best guys
and humble teammates you would ever have
a defined leader and toughest guy you
could ever have at the position to treat
him this way if this is his final basis
the franchise is absolutely not only one
giant like it's unreasonable and
intolerable and he's a Walter Payton Man
of the Year Award winner I mean we could
go all and all about the the Eli Manning
resume or you want Eli Manning out in
front of the franchise the league he has
never had a bad day
he has always put his team first he's
always and I've given him I talk to you
lie every week
he's on my show every Monday I have
given a lie a thousand times to ferry
this coach I peed it up for him I have
teed it up for him all you had to do was
hit it down the fairway he has not one
time ever taken the opportunity or even
a little bit made a snide comment about
this guy and he could have a hundred
times he has had this coaches back he
has had his general managers back he has
had his teammates back when they drop
balls when they don't show up when they
don't play on he has never thrown a guy
on that team under the bus and they
treat him this way it is one of the
worst things I've ever seen and then you
know to act as if the entire New York
City metropolitan area hasn't had a
front row seat to Gino Smith's attempts
at being a starting quarterback you
replace it in which Gino Smith you would
have been better off if it had been the
youngster that have been well you
could've at least sold it to some of the
fans but you're going to tell me that
your plan to win this week out on the
coast against the Raiders and in the
weeks to come against the Eagles and the
Cowboys etc is the plate Geno Smith /
Eli Manning I mean who's gonna buy that
I and that's why I guess it circles back
to how John Merrow would give the the
big blue checkmark to something like
this because just a circle back to how
we started this conversation Mike
Francis a hero on the Rich Eisen show
you said that the Wellington Merrill
hallmark was never evaluate in real time
evaluate at the end of the season that
is the exact press release that the
Giants put out just a couple of weeks
ago saying we are not going to go in
real time here in this Twitterverse 21st
century about what Ben McAdoo is doing
what Jerry Reese is doing and then Mitch
so so what could it possibly be that the
John Merrow Wade that they that the
contractual obligation to the general
manager and the coach to let them decide
who the 53-man is on game day and then
in general that that that has to take
precedence over overruling them for you
Manning could that be I think rich di I
can't explain it because it doesn't make
any sense and it is completely on Mara
like okay and unguent like as we know
and we always give the Giants the
benefit of doubt on these because they
have been such a classy storied
franchise and they are held as you know
in such high esteem I mean in our town
the yankees and the giants are held and
complete high esteem compared to all the
other teams about most of the time i
mean they make mistakes but most of the
time doing things correctly i mean
they've been moments like when they
wouldn't pay for farah which I went nuts
about and Wellington Mara called me and
said I will correct that I mean so I
don't want to hear you yell about it
again but I will correct that as what he
told me and he did he paid stuff like
that but listen they all slip up George
slipped up but still they've always been
known to do things the right way but
this is so you know so atypical for them
and all I can say is that John decided
to let these guys hang themselves I mean
maybe that's what we're looking at maybe
he needs to sell a decision to fish I
don't know maybe that's part of this I
don't know I know they differed on
Coughlin I know that John really wasn't
comfortable scorner and Tisch wasn't so
I mean maybe there's something there
with back to do I don't know that though
there could be a split they've had some
splits in recent years so I mean maybe
that did or maybe John is so hung up now
on getting the dells contract
straightened away and worried about
league matters where he is a pivotal
figure maybe taking his eye off the
giant ball right now I mean you know
they have meetings today in the city
they're dealing with Jerry they're
dealing with the compensation committee
of which John is one of the six and John
let's be honest John and Rooney and
blank are the three guys they are though
they are The Wind Beneath Fidel's wings
all right we all know that they are the
three guys who are the most Pro Bedell
so maybe that's what he's worried about
right now he's not worried about his own
mess he's worried about the leak mess
and the league has a mess on its hands
for the first time in its life it has a
that I can remember in my life with the
league the league has a mess on the
staff so you think you want
in Jacksonville maybe Eli next year what
do you think for him our poll question
is where you think he wants out listen I
think Tom Coughlin's holds him an
incredibly high esteem first of all let
me say this I am completely and Eli has
not been great this year he's heard
footsteps he has clearly tried to get
rid of the ball way too early too many
times but he also has been the victim of
incredible drops bad route running and
an incredibly poor offensive line Eli
he's a very good thrower the deep ball
and that's what he should be doing he
was not a high percentage guy he's a
home run hitter that's what he's always
been he's a big playmaker he's a big
game maker and he's a home run hitter
that's what he is he isn't a guy who's
gonna think in funky to 75% that's not
who he is he's a guy who's gonna throw
interceptions but he's a guy who is
gonna win the big game and he's always
been great big games he's always been
great late in games that is his MO he
would be perfect on a team like
Jacksonville that just needs a
quarterback it couldn't be a better fit
that's all that team's missing isn't Eli
Manning and I think Eli Manning has
plenty of football in them I think he's
a young going to be a young 37 he's
young mentally he's young physically
he's never been hurt I think he's got a
lot of football left in him I don't
think this is the last chapter at all
for him and you know what I wish the
Giants would have released them now it's
very hard to go another team in season
but that could have worked and I think
it would have been a lot of fun to watch
because right now they have problems
with bortles that would have been the
perfect fit with a running game with a
defense that could have been fun to
watch it's really good I guess to bring
it all full circle that's why you know
with what you're saying
obviously Eli is part of the 2 & 9
there's no question about that Mike no
quite but so that's why you could say
we're going to this kid from Cal we need
to see what we've got to see if we are
you know the reality is we're gonna pick
top five there's all of these kids at
quarterback we got to see what we've got
but to come up with an organizational
plan where you tell Eli that you're
gonna start then sit who and that who
leaves that meeting saying let's sell
that to Eli and he's gonna buy it as to
anything other than an insult
it makes no
since in the Maga um eating bet thinking
that was a good idea the bottom line and
they have disrespected McAdoo has
disrespected Eli for two years you know
why because he's an easy guy to
disrespect because he doesn't have any
ego he's the rare he's the red top
player the rare big leader may NFL Man
of the Year two-time MVP in the Capote
who doesn't have an ego
that's very rare we know that we but
that's who he is
he never react to criticism he never has
he is the ultimate gentleman but what he
is
he also he's got a lot of John Wayne in
them he is so tough and so mentally
tough he's always there in the big spot
he will always be there for a team in
the big last one for you Mike when you
came on we were last you were promoting
that 34:30 about you and mad dog and I
skate this was Bo you know obviously in
the summer and I asked you when you go
off the air mid-december how many wins
the Jets have they have they're gonna
have more than the Giants and and now
the Giants are sitting Eli Manning using
the old jet quarterback so the question
is have the Giants become the Jets Mike
they have at least for this year
hopefully it is a short-term ality and I
actually actually somebody say this I
actually think the Jets are on the right
course
I think mechag Ninh is the right
architect the one thing he's got to do
everybody's got a blind spot he's got
one sigh Hackenberg he's got to get past
they'll get himself a quarterback he
needs to hit the homerun on the
quarterback if he does that I think Jets
fans of which I know you were one are
going to be very happy with him I don't
know about [ __ ] I'm unsold I like
that they come out and play hard I like
some of the game plans his in-game stuff
is very weak that he needs to be more
forceful I've talked to Todd about that
I really think he can get that way I
think he's a 50/50 deal I could go
either way on him but I think a cognate
is a given and I think they have a
defensive infrastructure that is
terrific
those young safeties are wonderful I
think
building a good defense I think the
offensive lines being built they need a
home run hitter at wide receiver but I
think they're very close to being pretty
good now the Giants you know what it's
going to be a very interesting it's not
their way to do a quick about-face but I
think this year has been so bad so off
the charts bad from what it was supposed
to be then I think that I think
everybody's gonna walk the plank well if
you and I don't speak before you sign
off Mike I just want to say on behalf of
anybody who does what I'm doing for this
show speaking it to a radio Mike talking
sports and calling and getting callers
and and and batten it around with with
real people every day I say thank you
and then as a Staten Island or born in
Brooklyn raised in Staten Island on
behalf of everybody in New York City in
the metropolitan area thank you as well
that's very nice thank you that's very
very very generous of you I appreciate
it want to have nice holiday Thanks
you bet that's Mike France s assuming
you and you were so rich isin show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience